Thanksgiving Day gives us a chance to share
a meal with family and friends.
It also offers a time to reflect upon those
who are less fortunate and the things we can
do to make sure no child goes hungry in this
country.
In 2018 alone, Americans gave more than
$50 billion to organizations like food pantries,
homeless shelters, and soup kitchens.
Nearly a third of charitable giving occurs
during the holidays, and helping to feed the
hungry is a top volunteer activity for Americans.
The federal government plays a role too. It spent
close to $100 billion in 2018 on programs
like SNAP, school lunches, and nutritional
assistance for new moms and infants.
Thanks to these efforts, fewer than one percent
of children in 2018 reduced their food intake
because of a lack of money.
Good nutrition is essential for child
development and human flourishing.
On this day and throughout the year, it is
important to remember our shared responsibility
as a society, not just the government, to
make sure that child hunger in this country
remains rare.
How do you plan to help the needy this Thanksgiving?
Let us know on our poll.
Also let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.